WESLEY CHUN: This
is Wesley Chun.
Here at Google,
we want our tools
enable you to build
the next killer app.
In this Dev Byte,
I'll introduce you
to the core components of
the Google Cloud Platform.
I'll also share a few stories
of what others have already
done with it.
Once you're familiar with
the services in the platform,
you too will be able to leverage
Google's vast resources,
experience, and performance to
help you power that great idea.
At Google, we're always thinking
about scale and innovation.
Here are some of
the research papers
we published over the
years, many of which
have led directly to services
in the Google Cloud Platform.
You already know Google Search
and YouTube and Gmail services
which run at Google scale.
What if you could take
advantage of that kind of scale
and innovation that's
behind our services,
but for your big idea?
This is where the Google
Cloud Platform steps in,
enabling you to take your
app to the power of Google.
What is the Google
Cloud Platform?
Well, in brief,
it's a collection
of services organized into three
categories-- compute, storage,
and application services
to help your apps scale.
Pick and choose which
services you want,
and only pay for the
resources you use.
We begin with the
compute category,
where we've got Google App
Engine and Google Compute
Engine.
Let's start with Compute
Engine, our computing solution
at the infrastructure
as a service layer.
Create Linux virtual
machines and connect to them
like any other network computer.
They feature persistent disks
with snapshotting, live virtual
machine migration to get
around those pesky maintenance
periods, networking and
firewalls, load balancing,
and regional zones
for high availability
to implement your
technology stack and solve
really big problems with.
How big?
Well, here's an example
of really big data.
Let's say you were
going to get married
and you wanted a huge wedding
and needed prepare invitations
for your closest
15 billion friends
and relatives, which is roughly
7 billion guests from Earth
and the other eight
from other planets.
Well, anyway, let's
just say we had that
and you were organizing the
addresses, roughly about
100 bytes each,
for the envelopes.
But to make sure there
aren't any duplicates,
you would need to
sort all of that data.
Well, the MapR did
something similar last year
using Hadoop on Compute Engine
to set the minute sort record.
Their app was able to take 15
billion 100 byte directors,
meaning 1.5 terabytes,
or 1,500 gigs of data,
and sorted it all in
less than a minute.
On top of this, they were
able to reproduce this result
consistently across multiple
runs and different cluster
configurations.
Click the link for more details.
The other Compute
solution is App Engine,
our platform as a
service offering.
This solution is for developers
who want to be more hands off
and don't want to deal that
much with system administration.
So components living between
the hardware and your app,
such as the operating system,
the database, and web servers,
are all managed by Google so
you can focus on your app.
Build your solution
using familiar languages
like Java, Python, PHP, and Go.
Upload your code and let Google
take care of everything else.
Snapchat is a highly popular
photo sharing service
which serves more than 350
million photos or snaps a day.
What got them to scale
to where they are today?
Google App Engine.
Google Cloud Storage is for
your massive data repository.
Store any number of files and
blobs of virtually any size
securely with controlled
access to users,
as well as apps and other Google
Cloud Platform services that
can process and
analyze your data.
Song Pop is this
generation's name
that tune app running
on Google App Engine.
Along with Google Cloud
Storage, their app
serves more than 18
terabytes a day of music
to its 80 million users.
Google Cloud SQL is the fully
managed, highly available
relational database
service in the cloud.
Create, configure, and
use MySQL databases,
but host it in our data centers.
The standard MySQL
wire protocol lets
you connect to Cloud SQL
from any app anywhere.
And it also supports JDBC.
Free yourself from replication,
encryption, patch management,
and backups so that you
can focus on your solution.
One of its best
features is its pay
per use model, where customers
can opt to pay for a database
only when it's being used, and
then for inexpensive storage
the rest of the time.
Google Cloud Data
Store is the place
to store your NoSQL
key value data.
It's a fully managed service
which automatically handles
sharding, replication,
and scaling.
The storage mechanism is
schemeless and supports either
object based or SQL-like queries
as well as Asset transactions.
Cloud Datastore is
the same technology
that powers App Engine's
native data store.
Google BigQuery is an
exciting, massive data analysis
tool that lets you make
queries on data sets
that were previously impossible,
difficult, or significantly
time consuming-- data sets such
as baby names for the last four
decades, every word
written by Shakespeare,
or global historical weather
station data since 1929.
Using BigQuery, you can
analyze terabytes of data
in mere seconds using
SQL-like queries.
Here in BigQuery's
interactive web console,
you can issue ad hoc queries
against your data set.
Take it for a test drive with
one of these free public data
sets today, such as the
ones I just mentioned
or this particular
query, which lets
you pull up the five top
most updated Wikipedia pages.
Google Cloud Endpoints
enables you to seamlessly
create APIs or application
endpoints to your service,
allowing you to more easily
add new web or mobile front
ends to your existing service.
It's the glue between
your app's front end
clients and your back end.
Your web or mobile
clients connect
to Cloud Endpoints
via Google App Engine
so that you can go back
end services there or have
skeleton codes sitting on
App Engine for those requests
to your actual back
end, whether it
be on Compute Engine or
other external servers.
Security via data
authorization is automatically
handled between the front
ends and App Engine.
There is even a tool that
generates border plate client
side code in Java for
Android, Objective C for iOS,
and JavaScript for
generic web access
to help you get
going even faster.
So that's the Google
Cloud Platform--
what it's done for others
and most importantly, what
it can do for you.
We look forward to helping
you with your next big idea.